foreign
what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation I am joined with Andrew the Gordon I've
already watching today Andrew watching some Real
Steel Real Steel from Sean Levy who is reuniting
the Hugh Jackman for Deadpool and Wolverine movie
I am so excited for this I don't know anything
about it I think there's like a father-son
story if I'm not mistake that's probably
the one thing I know about it what are they doing
this let's find out something about robots I yeah
this is a weird intro ladies and gentlemen
leave a like on this video punch that like
button that'd be very much appreciated also I
want to say thank you to everyone who's been
buying some real rejects apparel that's right
real rejects we have our own merch that we uh
create ourselves www.rejacknationshop.com
look at this design look at that design
look at that design we also sell some marble
tees we got more in store that is coming up
very soon so stay tuned ladies and gentlemen
thank you again it's one of the best ways to
support the channel and as always full-length
watch long where you sync up with your own copy
of Real Steel available for super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page we also cover several
shows exclusively over there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included Andrew
do you have a pun you've been waiting to take why
do you have to put me on the spot like that you
know I'm not good at coming up with puns but
I will still I am oh well there I guess that
was what do you think I'm Roxy here I don't
have any friends let's just roll that in yeah
oh
buff alcoholic he is so out of his range
Phil Panther you want Chad money too
Ambush yeah you see him Ambush this
oh
cool it's one of those like
near-distant future movies
looks really good I love how everything is moving
too when he hits it what are you doing can we
can we get five dollars
I won five dollars immediately could be wrong
but I believe those little girls are Sean
Levy's children you need to stop following
directors children's around yes that's what
I do I was told my bot was fighting at 800
pounds here hey hey that is not 800 pounds
away fight the bull Pam I saw you you're staring
up in the ceiling at the Sam Houston center with
the taste of my right cross oh so he's a boxer
why don't we make this more interesting my bad
against your bull straight up I'm a 20 grand
when it takes off you got 20 Grand Challenge wow
really he really made that
a lot more interesting we
had any fans of robot robot boxing here today
[Applause] right it's like Rock'em sock'em
he really does look amazing those effects are
incredible yeah especially in brightly lit
Sky it's really hard to pull off they
usually have to Shadow it up so much
I'm so scared that the Bull's gonna wreck
it why is it fighting a bull why
isn't just fighting another robot
oh that's gotta be like mocap or
something man it looks way too good
damn that's awesome chappie likes the bull
ouch I don't like seeing this bull get beat up
dude pay attention stop looking at the are you
serious what are you doing he was mesmerized
by how horrendous looking that blonde girl was
still in this just hop hop oh damn he's gonna owe
so much money I have lost limbs as
Wolverine you can do this oh God ah
it is getting murdered it's like
I'm trying to get up but you keep
looking at blonde women in the stands [Applause]
ah bro do you have 20 grand now
he owes money to Jack Bill and
this other guy who really has a Southern accent
just listen to us do you recall Carolyn
Fallon it's my ex-girlfriend have you
seen her in like 10 years what does she
want nothing she died ah recall Max Kenton
he's my son he's got to be like nine or
eleven eleven is he dead too no he's fine
in the world so is he dead too Mother
Caroline Fallon deceased oh recognize
the actor yeah there's a kid from The
Sixth Sense young Thor first movie
what Haley Joel ostman was not in
the first Thor movie my husband
noisy boys for sale damn he's still so buff
I know for an alcoholic who's always on the
road gotta get in shape for that come on
Greg got a demand for the buttons being
in shape do you even remember me Deborah
Caroline's sister yeah please take a seat
oh he's the most likable deadbeat I've
ever met you're taking all the time you
need you better get in good with his family
they got some moolah use that checkman charm
I'd like to at this juncture step out and
call my attorney that's all right oh he saw
The Ring yeah I'm pretty sure you saw The Ring
by that close-up on the ring you know Deborah
really wants to adopt Max I'm up for it but
um 75 grand you're serious wow he would sell
his own kid like that we're supposed to go to
Italy this summer with my oldest friend and his
wife two months in Tuscany and all over Roger
sephoria sounds nice such a prank you're gonna
tell your wife I'll only sign over custody to
her if I get to spend the Summer with the kid
first let's tell her how guilty she made me
feel for being such a terrible absentee dad
this guy is such an [__] your honor I'm
really happy we all took the time to make
the best decision for everyone is he gonna
regret that decision oh I got the money take
him to Talus Jim and I'll meet you there
wow you know when I heard the title was
Real Steel I thought it was about robots not
this guy's heart a creepy the robot in a box
thousand dollar robot when you owe
me six grand rent because three no
six chemistry you're really gonna sell
your dad's gym if you don't make rent
I can't make payments and I won't have
a choice your father would climb out of
his grave and kick your ass there are so
many personal things at stake right now
don't don't do that
it's narcissistic charm on you 50 Grand as
promised numbers right and contact info over
hopefully she doesn't see his back pocket
you did the right thing giving me custody I
think Caroline would have wanted that back
in New York on August 27th that's a deal
he's such a douchebag I really do
like the look of the film though
yeah interesting shot do you know where
they're going it'll like how do they get
stuck here with you relax kid you got a whole
life of fine living ahead yeah uh did Marvin
give you that money I like how intuitive he is
yeah man he's a precocious child I'm Bailey Mac
meet your new mom and dad give me fifty thousand
dollars to sign you over tour will you shut up now
you sold me just to take care of you just give
me half the money and you won't have to oh I
told your aunt I get you to New York at the end
of the summer not your concerned Frank Deborah
really is his son's father my Father's son how
much of a challenging [__] they both are to
each other washed up alcoholic arguing with his
child this is way out of Hugh Jackman's range
never seen him play a role like that damn
damn that's really cool I've watched that
fun oh great no the beginning of their bonding
two things yeah effects are really
good though right left uppercut
maybe we have to speak another
language the little boy figure it out
it's really smart you can make a lot
more money with the kid around how
the hell do you know Japanese video
games makes sense yeah that's how I
know Japanese too yeah she said to English
and I found his command Matrix gravity one
that is pretty cool coming with you no
you're not I'm either coming with you
or you're fishing for your
sick of negotiator [Music]
I do like the similarities
between them get in just
actually the groundedness of the world is
very well realized like when you're not
around the robots and then when
the robots come into the screen
yeah it actually feels seamless
and believable absolutely yeah
what I love about Sean Levy is films
have a lot of heart and he's really
good at capturing wonder even if there's
like a hint of cheese in them you know
it's Furniture playing Eminem with
uh yeah you want to fight Midas 50
000 guaranteed winner takes off they can make
enough money to pay back that money that that
for the kid was she taking under card five
make a little cash and get the hell out of
here I love how smart this kid is and I'm
gonna make some real cash we'll take Midas
you've gotten into so much trouble already like
why don't you take some good advice at some point
I mean arrogance is part of
his character arrogance and ego
that's so cool [Music] here top
looks like Iron Giant with a mohawk
where do they shoot this I don't know
I mean this background it has to be
green screen because yeah it looks really
great yeah I love this set though for this
this is a really fun movie who's ready for
some destruction let's get ready [Music]
is it quicker to be dictating
than it is to be controlling
gravity slam up down
get your 50k ah they're bonding
[Music] Shield
little boy say something give him advice
thank you
oh God damn you can feel it
come on man God this is so frustrating [Applause]
so frustrating boy
do you have 50 Grand you never should
have taken that fight thanks genius
you even think about the stuff you do
before you do it I like how the sun's
Sun's telling the dad that
this place is what I want
you don't need yours throw away oh look into your
soul sir don't look at me like that way get in the
truck I want to see this version of Hugh Jackman
interact with Viggo Mortensen from Green Book just
too high energy East Coast people look for some
parts I'm coming with you huh that drink has my
heart pounding if I send this truck by myself
my head will explode I love this kid I just
love how high energy agitated huge accurate's
performances the entire time it's almost like
cartoonishly at like the entire movie why would
he not be with so many people thousands of dollars
a bit of that Michael Bay like Transformers
and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
cinematography to it but looks better than both
of those at human Fighters human body so couldn't
give the people what they really wanted true No
Holds Barred violence looks like in Jurassic Park
dinosaurs weren't enough we got to create
some monstrosity crazy dinosaur s careful
careful you're on a clip ah
this Jurassic Park was a good reference to make
little boy
that additional fifty thousand
dollars you better get that kit
that's the only reason to save
him no nothing else matters
did they land on like a bitching
robot I would assume so but not
sure what can you see what that is because I can't
it looks like there's a robot grabbing him yeah
is it bumblebee I I don't know and it it grabbed
him or it was just buried there don't have to
be scared it's okay I gotcha you're gonna give
me your other hand oh my God he's protecting him
it's like he's actually being a father one two
that was sweet
try to get it out what is it whoa generation
one we've got a winner Charlie I think there's
a whole robot in there this is Arc he's gonna
[__] that's not gonna happen in this movie
taking them with me saved my life if I saved your
life let's go you want that piece of jump you get
the card yourself I'm through here just never
listens to him not only did it physically save
them it's gonna save them financially It's Gonna
Save their relationship as father that's not going
to happen Greg yeah probably not sorry I'll do
one yeah it's different when you do it it hurts
oh wow did his dad really make him do it by
himself yeah teaching him character I do like
how it maintains this small town Vibe at the
same time like Countryside and all that you
know it's cool it's pretty neat there's a lot
I really like about this movie it's really fun
it's understandable I don't know how he had
enough energy to even lift his arms but that
was so cool we just waited there the whole time
and did it did it helps but one together you're
brilliant at this there's some good stuff here
no there's nothing here there is look Charlie
like a conglomerate of them all some
type of hybrid he's generation two but
barely we half the night dragging him
out of there he's mine oh he's yours
yeah but the parts we're putting
in them are mine then it's ours
hey guy
how may I be of service they're in harmony
with each other they're connected got a
shadow function that's that's rare
oh so he can actually box hell yeah
I really like the music by Danny Elfman too so far
[Music]
double meaning the first can we get him
a fight he's a sparring bot right Bill
to take a lot of hits but never dishing
out any real punishment you always try to
sell them off for parts can't you
get him a fight listen to the kid
the Elfman score does really help
to provide the fantasy element
get our cardio in you got to lose some weight
[Music] this is really cool because it's feeling
like an actual sentient robot versus the
other ones we just felt manually controlled
[Music] everything is Created from Adam's creation
[Music]
he's like the dad you never had
someone [Music] your secret safe with me it is
living it was kind of grew up in this gym my
daddy dad your dad and you always mentioned
the day that's Charlie we like the boxer
quit no fear I just know him as a deadbeat
the top Contender number two in the world and
Charlie was dancing with him he was beautiful
beautiful Michael Tandy rung my bell and went
on to be the undefeated World Champ for the
next three years so he knocked you out oh yes
did you ever fight for the title yeah you do we
leave in an hour I think it's fine I'll look it
up on Wikipedia I do feel like the Evangeline
character severely in hurry all she does is
talk about her dad and and I'm like I don't
really know her severely underused you mean
underwritten everything oh Underwood that's what
you wanted right me gone yeah that's what I wanted
you can tell in the subtext of her voice sir
and the way she talks about you she definitely
wants you gone yeah I hope in the next scene
she mentions her dad and or him entirely yeah
good night I think the the World building
around this is really really really well
done like they're grounded in reality just
like wonderful you know it just feels like
the next stage of the exactly how they set
up the world that it's just in the near
distant future behind the father-daughter
Zeus team they say your father's the money
and you are the Mind behind Zeus but I assure
you the man behind those belongs to the gray
is this talk machito's greatest
creation he's adaptive operating
system he recognizes patterns and
rewrites his fight code that's amazing
no matter what happens in that ring
the results of any fight is inevitable
well that makes bedding a lot easier I
would tell Charlie you know who to bet on
to the design of all the
robots is so good in this movie
that's like Rock'em sock'em like you said earlier
is that what you think boxing is who's beating up
some piece of Steel did they feed him and
I love it and I'm in it now not adapting
to the boxing world now well they need to be a
blend of the two there's a lovely place called
the zoo tomorrow afternoon you'll get your
fight it will be the end I told you I hate
burrito laughs
you've been up all night yeah I
cleaned him up broken some fight music
I saw that too he's in such good shape in
this movie I really think Hugh Jackman had
to play his performance a little bit
more it's slightly above real that
way we could like him otherwise he'd be
a very just unlikable guy fight my bro
my robe get in there with Metro I
want 500 for two rounds it's good
this kid is so good if he's still standing
[Applause]
I'm really fascinated by the world because
whenever they're traveling or going through
the city it just feels like our world and then
when they go to matches it's it's a completely
different kind of world [Applause] like the cast
of characters is so different [Music] [Applause]
she was like an apocalypse don't watch Adam
watch your opponent watch him watch out for
that funny looking opinion [Applause] ah
all right oh here comes the sledgehammer
[Applause]
Robo apocalypse
combine your brains oh poor guy
poor guy
I got some green fool oh
[Laughter] [Music]
I love this thing [Applause]
yeah he survived around [Music]
[Music]
I need the money I know that's why I did
this dude I love this kid they have good
chemistry too yeah but like a lot of kids
sometimes can be annoying characters and
he's he's not he's very well written
oh he's learning he's learning out
there I love it the dad's like
impressed with his son awesome
[Applause] [Music]
now what do you think about your son this
is so fun they've been losing for an hour
felt like Spider-Man 2 or Peter Parker's
just continuously losing all
film no I know I know [Music]
does the kid get any of that money I mean
he's the one who dragged him into the truck
and did the fight he doesn't need the
money I understand that but he wanted
the 50 Grand too remember from his dad can
you believe that the kids robot actually won
I know I love him gotta keep I can make more
than 50 Grand off of him I'm keeping this kid
it's their final match with Zeus gonna conflict
with when he has to bring him to New York I think
you should still give him away but keep the robot
I don't believe it in this change of heart stuff
you're gonna be a good dad one day yeah yeah
you could still kill yourself who was the kid
today's sponsor my child
[Music]
come on dance dance for me robot
go little white boy it's gonna say they
should maybe join So You Think You Can
Dance or America's Got Talent could
make a lot of money doing that as well
[Music]
and take the circuitry sleeve out
of noisy boy and it works I mean
he knows nothing but it works guys
they're teaching so many things in
video games nowadays I know God damn
I need to play more videos seriously
I need you to teach you in a box you
want to have a robot drink some Dr Pepper
box in a long time I'm not starting now you're
doing fine Max you don't need me my God he's
gonna find his passion for boxing again via
his kin I think Ali Sugar Ray prince Joaquin
gamut they all had their nicknames they had their
personas they all have Flair you might not have
much robot but with that dance you got Flair
Floyd Money Mayweather people want to see that
and we can make money hahaha I
won't do it unless you help me
I can't dance you're on your own there
oh we know you can dance oh yeah make
the robot drink Seven raw eggs trained to be
Wolverine this is what we gotta do that's it
I wonder how long a boxing train for just
curious do you think that guy he owes the 20
grand to at the beginning with the bowl
is that coming back at all or Nah Nah
Eminem do a uh this is Eminem and Royce the
five nine oh damn they're doing the dance
oh damn great swing damn oh like how that
robot's got a cowboy hat oh no more cowboy hat
damn making some he's like the original
plan the increments yeah [Applause]
this reminded me of Lionheart
now with Jean-Claude Van Damme
[Music]
Virgin America Spectrum Detroit Friday night
that's a league fight are you say fellas
you ready for the show somewhere in Italy his
Guardians are freaking out well I don't think they
do you think they know about that I'm pretty sure
they follow it religiously definitely they seem
like the characters who would I want you to be
relaxed okay Max no freaking out he's so anxious
it's fun you gotta have fun you understand me
we've come too far to get out there and freak
out and blow this whole thing we're gonna
have fun he's talking to himself so much
is this Hugh Jackman every day before he
goes on set this is me before I film with you
just gonna enjoy the reaction Andrew we're just
gonna do this don't worry guys he's he's actually
being serious you have been invited to lemkova
Suite One More Time sweet Zeus sweet dough
set up to the champ sweet I had a feeling that's
possibly oh my God I want Adam to just break
free and do his own thing now oh prisoner of
their bond ship I'm important fights tonight
so I'll get right to it you can offer oh for
the robot yeah I'd like to buy your robot
it'd be a useful spotting bot for Zeus and
for that I'm willing to pay 200 000 dollars
15 minutes away from getting in the ring with Twin
Cities my offer stands until the
starting Bell he's not for sale
over the top I love it I think
it's worth 200 Grand 200. man
Charlie we can go round and round this
all night long look at me look at me
the two-headed Tyrant [Applause] dude all
the sets for all the matches fantastic
oh my God it's like a Siamese robot
I was thinking that too I'm glad you
said it hailing from Parts Unknown at
home let's go Adam atom let's go atom
yeah that's gotta be mocap right yeah I think
it's a mocap robot yeah it's just way too good
that's a real robot on set I'm saying it's
not just like CGI It's gotta be vocab yeah
I love this I love it and I think
it's well Justified for this story
too look over there see those Geeks with the
joysticks and consoles they're controlling
everything that bot does this is the league
stand on that I'm a heads up about that
break why didn't we get the 200 Grand
oh he's been so incredibly overrun I love
Hugh Jackman's performance in this movie
the robot designs are so good in this
film too yeah that's right come on
boom it's so fascinating they
have two guys controlling it I
know it's like Pacific Rim I never
saw it Oh add it to the list okay
oh my God oh my God oh my ah oh
my oh my God this guy's got two
heads stop being in your own head wait wait wait
he's got a hitch in his shoulder
every time he throws that right
box to hit it stop talking about it yeah nice nice
[Music] [Laughter]
[Music]
block off oh yeah Charlie special whoa
oh she knows his moves [Music] [Applause] [Music]
I love this I'm loving it this is so fun [Music]
this is cooler than re-boxing although I'm sure
the many boxing fans out there are in disagreement
with me they haven't hugged yet they haven't
hugged yet it's not happening not happening whoa
what's he gonna say
I love how they're just letting him do it
who won't be named for raw lemkova
oh what is he doing okay I'm just
gonna find my robot and you think
you're my you're my control why not
the biggest shot Whoa We Are nearing the
finale we need to get there yeah suits
I mean would they would they still
saying the rocky Lots
oh [__] he's like let's get out of the ring now
would they still get paid just to fight though you
know does it work like that with a boxing match
they could probably still walk away with a lot of
money even if they lost you know they only win if
they lose if they only win money if they win the
fight all right 70 30 right yeah 70 for me and
30 for you that's very funny very very funny so
the progression of their relationship is very very
natural yeah they're taking their time they're not
rushing it even though it's obviously it would
happen of course but they're not rushing it oh my
god dude hey 20 grand guys back don't worry about
that that was a heck of a fight it was an amazing
fight that was a great job young man Oh I thought
I was joking when I said I beat you within an inch
of your life he thought that was a joke how about
that just give him the 20 grand use the robot I
have your money we don't have a problem Rick oh
I'm sure you do Charlie but I think we know it's
about much more than just money now don't we okay
125 30. you want 30 grand I got the money in cash
right here all right now the robot's gotta
get help them crap oh no don't not the kid
oh yeah use that boxing hey Ricky oh that's his
money leave him out of this oh oh damn Wolverine
oh [__] this is actual box that's cool
come on Adam come in there and help
oh your friends are real Dirtbag kid
America
damn the first time he called him his dad let me
call him daddy call him or his
father label given the title
oh man I called that and
all his lost moment people
oh his aunt uh boy I called her look at us we're
a mess fine she can leave Adam's fighting good
we can make the money back please call him
Dad yet legally she has custody so what what
can I do I think they would want to do what
he would little boy really wants you know
I don't want you money Marvin what at least
take the 50 Grand what do you want me to say
I'm sorry you decided to take the ride Max you
thought me you and him broke off in the chunky
we're gonna ride off into the sunset you don't
need to push him away like this man no you you
forgot who I was you deserve better um than me
he's doubting himself as a father especially
after he's got beat up man I tried okay I mean
what do you want from me I want you to fight
that's so sad oh it feels a lot deeper than I was
expecting it to be I think they wrote the little
kid a lot better than I anticipated it's actually
one of my notes very premature because we're still
actually watching it's one of my favorite
child characters sure sure I've seen [Music]
back to who they were at the
beginning of the story self-reflection
you're back I got to talk
to you about you or my dad
father just one once more
really looks like the set that
that particular gym looks like
the set of Ghostbusters where they
have the app perhaps go this way
it was like he was in your corner from day one me
come on I blew it that's the whole character okay
it is her acting is fine it's just the character
who's just like you said it's very underwritten
would know where to start
come on come on
oh there's a glow go get him Charlie
I know nothing about her character because
he loves your dad she really loves her dad
and everything about her dad she loves
Charlie she loves Charlie you have no
business being here that's true uh
you've got full custody he's yours
and and I know I've done all kinds of
wrong by this kid but if you'll let me
make a lot of money with him yeah we want to fight
Zeus and I'll bring him right back right yeah
and you slept on a shelf in a truck and it
was awful and dangerous really dangerous
came to tell you that I heard you I got it
I want to fight for him and I know you had
a bum ride Max and I wasn't there and I should
have been your mom was she was the coolest she
was I'm sorry about I haven't heard much better
day what happened with her and I can't get those
years back max but but I'm here right now and if
you're up for it I'm ready to fight hug hug hug
he was blocking that whole view
we got the Zeus fight no we didn't
well you've proven you're a good father so yes
one night thank you you know we'll
probably get our asses kicked but
at least we'll go down swing and on National
Television for everyone to see I mean the good
thing is it's not dangerous for him yeah
that's true like true he's not getting him
actually hurt yeah [Music] I want to see
the aunt and the aunt's husband watching
the match on their TV yeah they got to be on
one being like come on right hook left hook
[Music]
[Applause]
these characters man 100 cases Adam doesn't see
round two remember section 101 row C and you can
bring me my money right to my seat oh boy all
right really really he's one of the bad guys
do you have to have subtle racism to drive home
how bad it is yeah I said subtle racism very sad
yeah [Music] oh my God it's Shredder from the
2014 version best Turtles movie ever [Music]
so you're gonna just jump over I hope he flips
[Music]
oh superhero Landing in about scheduled for
five rounds they showed up they showed up I
guess I was we were wrong about that
being watching I mean he does have 50
Grand to spare so she's got some
front row seats are you ready for
[Applause]
Espin what a fun fictional Sports
Universe yeah never heard of it whoa
oh the dent Mark too damn
this is like what'd you look what kind
of fight did this kid get me involved in
oh second time
he just keeps getting back up man
I don't think getting his hands
up because then to do anything
back in there oh my God he's like
fighting dragon whoa if he dies oh no
for Christ's sakes Adam get up oh
Just Go the Distance dude command him to do
something though feel like you uh Charlie's
nuts thank you oh finally said something
though clearly never saw it coming advance
yeah you didn't see that man come on
there's like damn ah five seconds
left get out of the corner
wow yeah
[Applause] homeboy let's go home
how does it feel to be on
the other side of that punk
good Corners fear Fury damn gloves
would help it's like NASCAR Kenton
working his butt with a trifecta [Music]
let's go let's go the distance [Music]
oh my God this is April wow awesome this
is such a great match yes you call that
yeah dude look at the Den marks on his face he's
gonna probably take the controls I would imagine
whoa the spin move
lights are seeing Stars I think the
voice recognition is not responding
what you gotta get it but you
put the you have to box yourself
that's like Donnie Yen in it man you can't
hear me you gotta do it yourself sounds in
once again what I like about Zeus is the way
he moves is just like like an actual robot
there's not much in the shoulder so he's
like robot and a brawler at the same time
yeah you've got actually box man this
movie's giving me everything I want no way
come on you have to fight the last round
you gotta believe in yourself there's more
than 50 Grand on the line right now are
you kidding me with those eyes [Music]
damn it it's like this is what I got in shape for
for this movie for this scene I know you can't
hear me but you can see me so watch me this
is so cool are you talking to a robot I know
watch me throwing his own line back at him I like
that [Applause] commands see him
in the background that's so cool
whoa are you singing Charlie can you Shadow
Boxing just outside the room this is so great
he's fighting the last round of this fight
against us back up against the ropes again
[Applause] oh he's waiting waiting for
an opening I think personally oh [__]
oh [__] it's like Rocky taking the
hits he's tiring him out I'll Tell You
Folks the champ looks tired yeah oh my gosh
guys they're clever legging it [Applause]
believe it Adam is taunting Zeus Mr Turbo
he's actually asking for more oh yes
fuel Gatling guns of Zeus's blows [Applause]
they're all Fighting For Adam yeah foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that was amazing
that's so cool that was so awesome
oh he brought his dad that is beautiful
yeah that is beautiful he's got a big
smile on his face and his dad's love for
boxing yeah oh it's the he's beautiful
isn't he oh I love that shot you can
see both of them yeah isn't he beautiful
oh no matter what we win let's
get an action box oh oh yes my man
you want more to knock his head off
knock his head off oh my God he's got to have
won right oh the actual glass oh say my dad
would be proud say it if she does I'm just I'm
I swear and still world robot yeah it's Rocky
it doesn't matter though it does not matter
he went the distance there true I know
the whole crowd is against them now it took a
little longer than we start but the result is as
expected she's the Russian girl from Rocky IV any
comment on the absolutely humiliating near loss
yeah it looks like he's gonna deck him
okay they're already
ready I like the name sound of that what
do you say to that sounds pretty good to
me call him dad right here give me what I
want [Music] [Applause] he's calling him dad
[Music]
movie [Laughter]
really heartwarming story I need you to know
don't worry I know your secret's safe with me
[Music]
what's he gonna do yeah [Applause] [Music] yeah
they may have lost the match but they
won the people's hearts and respect
that's such a great shot at the
end too crying you're crying
now let's watch Hotel Transylvania for Via
Amazon's recommendation I haven't seen any
of those but that's like the perfect uh I would
skip right to four as well that's like the perfect
movie to go to I would imagine after this ah yes
no seriously that movie was again the only thing I
knew about that movie you uh obviously knew was
a father-son story I only knew that there was
boxing and robots um so it was a lot deeper than
I was expecting it to be which I was pleasantly
surprised about I think that was the obviously you
know no pun intended but it was the heart of the
film uh obviously the character transformation
of uh Hugh Jackman's character Charlie uh just
what his son was able to uh you know help him uh
transform from a heartless bastard into uh you
know a wonderful loving father who made some good
money off of him of course um but transformed yeah
right right that's the the key word here so you
couldn't get a pun out of mirror there but yeah
I'm just planning away but oh by the way I gotta
interrupt you I keep forgetting to do this I gotta
interrupt you if you are listening to our review
on uh you know pot uh like any of our Spotify or
apple or anything like that please rate this video
we just watched Real Steel literally start talking
about right after I have a tear I just wiped off
my face he did I can see it right now seriously
he did yeah um but seriously that uh I I have
not seen many Sean Levy films I've only seen
Night at the Museum so have you seen free guy
I have not that's awesome I have not seen any
but I was already excited for definitely not
worth reacting to yes definitely what everyone
says no it's not the kind of movie that's words
or reaction yeah but um I was already extremely
excited for Deadpool 3 but this film just got
me even more ramped up and I I gotta say too
um I'm not the biggest fan of uh child characters
I think they're very difficult to direct and very
hard to write I was extremely pleasantly surprised
with not only the acting of this young boy who of
course as I mentioned a few times played the
young Thor in the Kenneth branagh's film the
same year 2011. uh he did a fantastic job uh but
I just I loved his relationships and interactions
uh with Hugh Jackman it was just to me again the
heart of the film I just thought he was so well
written I loved how intuitive he was and uh just
those were my favorite scenes in the film I know
probably most uh the most entertaining scenes
of the film of course are the the robots and
all that but I I loved the scenes with him
and his dad but what'd you think of the film
Thai I hated it I know I think that any criticisms
I would have are not necessary I think they they
came and went and I don't really feel like they
need to be something to really harp on my only
real thing was about Evangeline Lily like it
was it wasn't fun with her I like her I like
Evangeline Lily um despite whatever controversy
she might have had I like her performance here
and uh I believed I thought they had good camera
she had good chemistry with them regardless uh
and then my only real complaint is like she's very
she's very underrated this is one of those movies
that's like it's it's predictable right from
the jump like it's extremely predictable movie
but at the end of the day you're like but I wanted
to go down that path and I I want the plot turns
to happen that this movie is very much obviously
setting up you want it to go there and it's all
about the execution so you still get the catharsis
you're still having fun I pretty much had a smile
on my face from beginning to end with this film uh
the performances themselves Hugh Jackman I thought
had such an energy here it was so it was so big
and so heightened and it wasn't like too over the
top but it was like just over the top enough where
I found it very Charming because and I think I do
think it was required due to the fact that his
character is such an unbelievably cold-hearted
[__] in this world of a robot fighting boxing
matches that he needed to be that so that way he
still be charming and he's the leading character
this is a big Hollywood movie so he's got to be
likable to it because he's so Charmed it's it's
like he's so cold but so unbelievably Charming
at the same time and the way he is about his kid
that it needed to be a little bit over the top in
order to sell it you know and so I thought he was
great I agree with every point you made about the
the kid I thought that he was a wonderful actor
I'm sure by this point in his life he is an adult
officially and I thought he was a really nice
addition and the way their relationship evolved
like yeah you know the plot beats are gonna go you
know that yeah they're gonna start off distant but
by the end of this movie they're gonna be like
a real father and son and he's gonna learn about
himself and find his roots again and realize that
he's just out of his walled up his entire time and
he's going to learn to love his dad like you know
you know exactly where it's all going but the way
we got there via this plot point of them finding
um harmony with each other and and kinship and
bonding via this robot fighting Journey I bought
it I thought it was believable and the the little
moments that they would have with them of how
they got there were the things that made it feel
rewarding and had me invested because it's like as
well I thought the plot beats were predictable of
course certain scenes that they would give us I
did it like I didn't think we'd go to a zoo with
an apocalyptic fighting I didn't really anticipate
that they would find some special robots together
that they would put together themselves and that
would be the thing you know like I didn't see that
coming you know I mean I did once you they pulled
it out of the rubble but you know what I mean like
yeah before it had happened I didn't anticipate
that uh yeah I I think that it was just a truly
entertaining film that ultimately just kept giving
me what I wanted with a true it had such a spirit
and a heart to it and the fighting Andrew what
did you think of the fighting the fighting was
great it was really entertaining but also like it
it felt I know it's robots and probably mocap like
you said I don't know but it it felt grounded
as well like I mean I really felt like I was
watching boxers really fighting even though again
it was robots but I think you made a great Point
while we were reacting like they did such a good
job of making it I mean keeping the actual World
grounded not so futuristic that when we did get
the fighting or the robots actually doing their
things the illusion became so real you know what
I mean you bought it yeah so I thought that was a
really smart choice and I think again to another
point you made about yeah there's a lot of plot
beats that you know are gonna happen which a lot
of times I prefer not I I don't care for knowing
things that are gonna depends on the kind of movie
though yeah of course of course but because the
execution here is so good and the interactions
are so good I don't mind it yeah as much so like
who gives a shame yeah for sure and that's why it
didn't bother me in any way shape or form I mean
I was and also too another thing I really loved
too there were two other things I really loved I
loved that they were really taking their time in
their relationship like they could have completely
rushed then oh okay uh like after a couple scenes
that they're uh they're really getting along and
sorry I just realized too because I kept making
compounding jokes about like oh alcoholic buff
guy this is a stretch rip alcoholic buff guy
who's arguing with this kid is a structure it's
not not just that alcoholic buff guy on this
relationship with his with his strange child
on the road it's like so Logan no I was thinking
Logan I didn't even factor in no I definitely was
thinking Logan a couple times throughout the film
for sure absolutely yeah definitely but uh yeah I
love that they they really you know they let the
film breathe or in terms of their relationship
they let it breathe they didn't rush that uh the
you know the transformation of their relationship
where they you know kind of met in the middle and
uh bonded I love that uh so you know I bought it
more but also too it didn't feel like it was
a slow burn like I thought the film was really
paced well at the same time yeah um so yeah I
know I mean a lot of goods I was a lot deeper
than I was expecting it to be too like again
the only thing I had known about it was it was
a boxing film with robots that's all I remember
from the trailer years ago yeah I didn't know
anything about this a strange Sun [__] I just I
remember I heard something about a father and son
movie and and robots fighting but I I I couldn't
tell you like exactly what the plot was at all
um and and I thought that them I thought the I do
think that at times when they would go into the
the world of the of the matches that it could feel
a little bit jarring to the juxtaposition of the
real world that it was fleshing out but I actually
wouldn't have it any other way because because it
would feel like so realistic and then suddenly it
was like oh now we're stepping into like a comic
book you know they would have this juxtaposition
but the right the the the way the the robots were
designed I thought was really cool just about
to ask you that yeah I feel like they wanted to
set this up for a franchise but I appreciate the
variety you know I think what I would have liked
is uh just to I guess semi further enhance the
experience is in terms of the choreography and
the movement per robot to get a little bit more
like something that made their style unique but
more distinct yeah yeah that so I think in
the final match with Zeus there's a certain
kind of it really was like Drago and Clubber Lang
versus Rocky Balboa you know totally and and they
take their Inspirations because there is a bit of
cheese to this movie that I think is intentional
it felt intentional there is a cheesiness that
was kind of permeating through the screen little
by little throughout the film where you could
feel some of it so much into earlier films there
were times it has a bit of that Lifetime movie
hard to it you know but it felt purposeful and
I enjoyed having that slapped on me absolutely
I did feel with Adam he definitely had his own
distinct and unique set of moves especially that
spinning move and then the flying punch I agree
with you it would have been nice to get that on
some of the other robots that he was facing I got
him I mean it was probably a purposeful choice I
couldn't imagine like budget wise and choreography
would have just taken a lot more work and all that
but um would have been a cool choice but yeah that
that match at the end though was like I I was not
expecting to feel so much suspense and tension
yeah I was in a film like with robots just going
at it in a boxing match so like I said this movie
was just a lot deeper than I was expecting it to
be and at the end like the heart of uh the heart
of it just a son and father like coming together
yeah it was a little predictable with the Beats
but again you don't care because it's executed
so well and I thought Sean Levy just again I'm
I'm really excited to see not only Deadpool 3
obviously but just more of his uh his other films
uh it's really really a good director yeah it's
all warmth to this movie man and the the music
I thought might have stood out a bit more just
because I saw Danny elfman's name slapped onto it
I'm only disappointed by the fact that I see Danny
elfman's name so I thought it'd be a little bit
more distinct I'll say this and first of all I'm
a die hard Danny Elfman fan I listen to him every
day at the gym Pandora's radio Danny Elfman
radio so I can say I am uh Edward Scissorhands
is actually my favorite film score of all time
Danny Elfman from first film of course was PeeWee
Herman's uh uh Herman's uh big adventure 1985
from 1985 to about 2003 up until Big Fish he was
the top three top four greatest composer from
that point on he still had a couple good scores
here and there Sweeney Todd was amazing I
haven't seen the film but the score he's had
a couple good scores but from that point on he
just has not been able to be old Danny Elfman so
I am total agreement there were a couple beats
in the film where dramatically I was really it
was touching but overall he's not been able to
be and again when I say ultimate of men we're
talking like one of the greatest composers of all
time so it's working yeah yeah no no for sure but
like when I've heard Terminator Salvation
or when I've heard Justice League I'm like
it's a mild criticism but I totally feel for
you I feel you because like when we hear the
old Daniel we're like damn this guy is
so freaking good yeah but totally yeah
um and then I guess uh again it's it's only
semi-jarm when I was saying they step into
the world of of the of the of the like the boxing
matches it's because the characters or so much out
of like a comic book or a cartoon you know what I
mean like you got the zoo people which feel like
a barbaric apocalyptic characters you got the
extremely Southern Cowboy guy you know you got
this guy who is like out of the Japanese gangster
World who's deciding that me and I did and I don't
know what accent that woman had but yeah they
felt like but I preferred a movie with a colorful
personality to its characters then Bland boring
characters and which kind of does trying a little
bit more of a spotlight on you know like oh that's
really kind of like dropped the ball a little bit
for the Evangeline Lily character I felt like they
just kind of wrote her like a little bit too dry
but overall everything I wanted to happen happened
everything I predicted would happen pretty much
happen right down to it's all those lost moments
you know you know what's going to happen because
you temporarily give the kid back whatever but I
thought the ground they fought they found too was
smart on that like he's not gonna just adopt
his kid uh he hasn't earned at the end of the
day he truly hasn't earned that to to have full
custody of the child but to be able to be in his
life and have a relationship with him that's what
really matters and that's what counts so I thought
I thought it might have gone down that's the one
part of the movie that I actually thought they
would have done that didn't happen where he would
end up adopting his game yeah we're not adopting
him yeah before the last match like okay he's
Gonna Be With You full time he's yours and which
wouldn't have been very realistic it's like wait
what has he done exactly yeah it's only been a few
months yeah they had a little bit of bonding and
I mean but I mean he got beaten up they've made
some money and he still abandoned him all these
years yeah exactly so I mean slowly but surely I'm
sure I'm sure the aunt and uh the aunt's husband
are gonna let him continue to spend time with him
and all that but he I'm glad they didn't go that
route because that would have taken away from the
crowdedness that we've gotten and how realistic so
far the film has been so I'm I'm glad they didn't
go through that Trope because that would have been
completely generic if they would have done that so
and this movie's funny too yeah I love the look
of it a lot some really striking cinematography
I loved all the sets too when I they had so
many different creative uh you know you could
feel that they I imagine this movie initially
underperformed or otherwise would have a sequel
by now I'm not I'm not gonna lie to you when I saw
the trailer for this movie it's not like I went I
this looks terrible I just I don't have any I love
you Jackman I'm like I'm not interested well I was
completely I'm pretty sure it got lost in the void
of like robot movies there's like Transformers I
think that's probably what it was I was probably
like I'm tired with the robot movies and I should
have given this one a chance but on the flip
side I'm glad I got to react to it for you guys
yeah man and um I I think I think I've seen every
Sean lady movie now at this point let me confirm
that I I don't know if I've seen I I think I've
seen the First Night at the Museum I'm not sure
let's see what I haven't seen of his before we
shout someone out all right hold on a second hold
on a second no no there's all these produced
43. there's a lot of show stuff though too
he's director of 43 movies that would be insane
can you imagine director 43 moving that's a lot
like yes it mainly shows I've even seen the
internship haven't seen any of these movies
oh he directed Pink Panther I've seen Pink
Panther unfortunately I haven't seen sorry
I've seen Cheaper by the Dozen as well I haven't
seen that he's a big fat liar I haven't seen that
didn't I think I watched maybe five minutes of
that movie oh there's actually a lot of movies
so it seems like he's upped his game as a director
yeah yeah I want to start a game but like not the
music so he did do all the night at the music I
haven't seen that I haven't seen two and three
I've I've only seen the first one um should I add
it to the list Craig Maybe maybe think about this
guys alrighty guys what did you think about this
film did you love it do you find it underrated
do you know where John put the list of the
shout outs for people because I'm looking
for it right tell us in the comment section
where did where did John put the shout out Greg
is trying to fight and we found it thank you
for letting us know people oh my God yes and
um hey before we go why don't we do a patron of
the day shout out all right Andrew yes here's what
we're gonna do today buddy what are we gonna do
today we are going to have in the honor of robots
we are going to have chat gbt oh boy write a shout
out all right so okay um between these three names
pick one okay uh let's go with Kevin smart Kevin
smart all right now let's um let's uh let's let's
play a little bit of Mad Libs here first of all
give me and uh give me an item an item any item
doesn't matter first thing you
can think of Andrew treasure
treasure very very broad out of their
treasure treasure give me an adjective
spot so the adjectives like do you
know what an adjective is I know it's
no yes maybe adjective is like uh you know uh
how do you explain what an adjective when you're
when you're describing like if something's big or
small or I'll just go with small you know like uh
um how can you explain explain to me what an
adjective is it's activity this is fun when an
adjective is all right so let's see if as far
as HSN modifies or describes or not a pronoun
get okay oh my God this is way too like a red
apple that's great like the red is the part
of it like apple is the object that's the noun
and red would be the adjective to describe it
you get it so something that describes
something in a way yeah uh like a blue cup
there you go yeah you're getting
it so um what was the first item
treasure treasure okay a gold okay let's go
with gold treasure adjective let's go with
um uh tiny and then um give me um an article
of clothing an article of clothing yeah
uh shorts shorts perfect thank you my
favorite gold treasure tiny shorts superhero
Iron Man favorite celebrity any
celebrity Arnold Arnold Schwarzenegger
okay this is an interesting illusion
which is gonna create a force
um and uh you're uh the the year
of one of your favorite movies
let's go 1991 Terminator 2. Okay and
then last thing an occupation or a job
uh let's do baseball base baseball player
okay I have I'm gonna write this I have a
YouTube channel where I need to shout out
my Patron whom I call a super sexy reject
his name is Kevin smart generate a shout out for
me incorporating these words which are gold tracks
keep it at 40 words or less Gotta Love AI all
right all right big shout out to our super
sexy reject Kevin smart rocking it like Arnold
Schwarzenegger in 1991. you're the Iron Man of
gold treasure keeping it cool those tiny shorts
like a pro baseball player thanks for your epic
support Kevin you're the real MVP like Chachi BT
oh dang it did it all that's smart like you Kevin
wow it took longer to get there than
it was to read it yeah thank you Andrew
had to explain adjectives this is for the sink
foreign